existen todo tipo de reacciones en los
sistemas biológicos que son
energéticamente favorables pero que no
van a suceder rápidamente o incluso no
van a pasar por su cuenta y la
fosforilación de la glucosa es un
ejemplo de eso entramos en detalle al
respecto en el vídeo acerca de
reacciones de acoplamiento y creo que la
llamamos fosforilación de la glucosa 6
fosfato y es muy importante porque al
colocar el grupo fosfato en una glucosa
permite que esté lista para dar inicio a
toda una serie de mecanismos biológicos
permite que la glucosa sea etiquetada
volviendo difícil para ella escapar de
la célula y es un mecanismo bastante
sencillo donde tienes un par de
electrones libres en este grupo
hidroxilo por aquí y luego si está en la
configuración correcta podría formar un
enlace con el fósforo en el grupo
fosfato
ahora bien la razón por la que no sucede
por sí solo aunque es energéticamente
favorable es que una vez que se forma el
enlace tienes electrones que van a ser
capaces de ir a un estado de energía más
bajo por lo tanto tiene un delta g
negativo
si estos son las moléculas antes de la
reacción esto es la cantidad de energía
libre que tienen antes de la reacción
después de la reacción tienen menos
energía libre han podido liberar energía
así que esto es algo que nosotros
consideraríamos como espontánea pero
para que la reacción ocurra se necesita
aplicar un poco de energía al sistema a
esto le llamamos nuestra energía de
activación y podrías preguntarte bueno
pero por qué necesitamos eso bueno
tenemos electrones que quieren formar un
enlace con este fósforo pero este
fósforo está rodeado de cargas negativas
este oxígeno de aquí tiene una carga
negativa y este oxígeno de aquí tiene
una carga negativa y cómo se pueden
imaginar a los electrones no les gusta
estar con otros electrones cargas
iguales se repelen entre sí así que para
que esta reacción se produzca o para que
ocurra con más frecuencia tiene que ser
catalizada
un catalizador es algo que hace que una
reacción ocurra más rápido o incluso
permite que la reacción simplemente
ocurra y cuando hablamos de
catalizadores en los sistemas biológicos
normalmente estamos hablando de enzimas
y más
y la forma en la que una enzima puede
catalizar esta reacción ya hemos hablado
de esto es que puede proporcionar
algunas cargas positivas podría proveer
algunas cargas positivas alrededor de
estas cargas negativas para alejarlas y
crear espacio de modo que la reacción
pueda ocurrir lo que haría una enzima
sería que esta curva en lugar de tener
esta joroba aquí la curva se vería algo
así
de manera que la reacción simplemente
puede continuar
pero qué son estas enzimas estas cosas
que pueden añadir algo de carga o que
pueden permitir que la reacción ocurra
de una manera determinada que pueden
doblar a las moléculas de una manera
determinada para exponer algunos enlaces
aunque pueden propiciar un entorno más
ácido o más básico que podría ser más
favorable para la reacción
qué son estas cosas aparentemente
mágicas bueno de manera general son
complejos proteicos y podrían tener un
par de otras cosas puedes verlas como
proteínas y quizá a veces van a ser
múltiples cadenas poli peptídicas juntas
o podrían tener algunos otros guiones
asociados a ellas pero en su mayor parte
son proteínas y las moléculas que van a
reaccionar que van a unirse a las
proteínas las llamamos sustratos
así que estos en esta reacción la
glucosa y el atp van a ser los sustratos
y el término general para la enzima que
ayuda a fósforo hilar una molécula de
azúcar de este tipo la llamamos exo
quinasa
así que puede ser que tengamos esta
proteína que se ve algo compleja
y el atp podría unirse a ella por aquí
atp es uno de los sustratos y luego la
glucosa podría unirse a ella aquí
entonces estos dos sustratos se unen y
la zona donde todo esto está pasando la
llamamos sitio activo porque ahí es
donde está toda la acción y a menudo
cuando tienes a los sustratos unidos son
capaces de interactuar con la proteína
para hacer que el ajuste sea aún más
fuerte para que sea aún más adecuado
para que la reacción ocurra entonces
toda la proteína se podría doblar un
poco para mantener a estos dos sustratos
ahí y llamamos a esto ajuste inducido
ajuste
inducido
entonces de dónde vienen estas cargas
positivas pueden provenir de las cadenas
laterales de los diferentes aminoácidos
en la cadena poli peptídica principal o
en la proteína e incluso podría haber
otros iones involucrados
de hecho en particular para facilitar la
fosforilación de la glucosa unión de
magnesio está involucrado para ayudar a
alejar a las cargas negativas pero hay
otros grupos cargados positivamente que
ayudan a alejar a la carga para que la
reacción pueda ocurrir así que eso es lo
que son las enzimas y tienden a
funcionar de manera óptima en ambientes
con ciertos valores de ph o ciertas
temperaturas en general las temperaturas
más elevadas permiten que hayan más
interacciones las moléculas tienden a
moverse más y a chocar más entre sí pero
si las temperaturas son demasiado altas
la proteína o la enzima puede dejar de
funcionar se podría desnaturalizar es
decir podría perder su estructura
original y lo que quiero que veas
hermosas y complejas que son estas
estructuras
seguramente puedes apreciar lo que te
estoy mostrando estas están en tus
células estos se encuentran en tu cuerpo
hay un montón de estas moléculas y estas
reacciones ocurriendo dentro de ti así
que espero que esto te ayude a apreciar
la complejidad de ti mismo como un
sistema biológico y también de todos los
sistemas biológicos
esto por aquí es una visualización de un
exo quinasa una variedad de la misma y
solo para darte una idea de la escala
esto es una molécula de glucosa y este
de aquí es un atp y se van a unir estos
son los dos sustratos que se unirán en
el sitio activo es posible que haya un
ajuste inducido donde esto se ajusta a
su alrededor a dejar la carga y podría
doblar las moléculas de una manera
determinada haciendo que sean más
propensos a interactuar juntando un poco
más estas moléculas y así vas a lograr
que ocurra la reacción y una vez que se
produce la reacción ya no va a querer
estar unida a los sustratos que ahora
son los productos de la reacción y
entonces se van a soltar
pero la enzima no ha cambiado y eso es
una propiedad importante de una enzima
no es que tenga un solo uso y ya puedes
seguir haciendo esto una y otra y otra
vez una enzima hará esto un montón de
veces y ahora lo que quiero mostrarte es
una visualización tridimensional que
obtuve en un sitio web así que déjame ir
a buscar eso
aquí está esta simulación o este modelo
y esto es en realidad una exo quinasa la
exo quinasa puede presentarse en
diferentes variedades y es una cosa
bastante bonita de ver y ésta ha sido
visualizada de maneras diferentes cuando
busques imágenes de proteínas en sitios
web o en algún otro lugar las
encontrarás a veces representadas con
estos modelos de barras y esferas a
veces las verás en modelos de espacios
llano y a veces las verás de esta manera
donde puedes ver las estructuras puedes
ver las hélices alfa aquí que estudiamos
cuando hablamos de estructuras de
proteínas y también se pueden ver
algunas láminas beta
y esto te da una apreciación de los
sitios de unión y de cómo pueden
interactuar esta de aquí es una molécula
de atp y luego aquí al lado creo que
está una molécula de glucosa y observa
que se han unido al sitio activo y ahora
pueden interactuar entre sí
la enzima like so quinasa en este caso
puede ayudar a facilitar la reacción la
fosforilación de la glucosa así que
espero que imágenes como éstas tengan
una apreciación de lo complejas y lo
hermosas que estas cosas realmente son